thank you
hey you are you wasting your time on
social media again your brothers and
sisters in the slum net from Norway are
establishing a mission a dawa Center
establishing a Masjid to convey The
Message of Islam is one of the best
Deeds a Muslim can do there's a huge
need for it in Norway you know this and
I know this so that makes the Lord even
greater so give generously and Allah
azzawajal give you even
do you feel like your life is purposeful
yeah yeah uh yeah yeah yeah yeah I would
say yes no yeah maybe
um yeah would you say a purpose or the
purpose of your life is great peace or
in the world be kind to people or be
with my friends family help other people
you know and be happy and have a good
life I would say to make myself and
other people happy it's like everybody
is so mean to each other mostly caring
about the people that I care about being
able to help the ones that I care about
live my life until it ends and have fun
in the meantime
now we're seeing more and more people in
Sweden and Scandinavian countries commit
suicide in recent times yeah why do you
think that is perhaps social media
influence and you see so much awful
things happening around the world and I
think it can really hurt uh they feel
bad alone lack of a purpose honestly
trying to find a place in this stupid
rat race not really succeeding searching
for meaning too much and not seeing a
meaning anymore because people are
searching for too much purpose we have
lost a religion community in a way with
people are lonely maybe because it's
depressing and we are not so social here
you know and
introvert there is something for them to
it was something a reason for them to
stay fantastic thank you so much for
your time that's all thank you we
connect hopelessness really hopelessness
everyone understands the link it's not
foreign link everyone understands the
link with hopelessness suicide not
wanting to live anymore with the fact
that someone does not have purpose
someone does not have meaning in their
lives and not just any purpose or
meaning
but those purposes and those meanings
which are concrete and those solid
meanings objective solid purposes and
meanings so that's what we're talking
about here and isn't it something
interesting and ironic at the same time
we've tried this in Norway and now we've
tried it in Sweden we're getting almost
identical responses frankly almost
identical responses the same blame being
casted on social media
but also the same realization that
without a life without meaning life
without purpose is a life not really
worth living and they understand even
why someone might want to end such a
life
hello
how are you my friend I just wanted to
ask you a question
right yes I am but just uh this is a
social experiment I'm asking for a few
questions maybe some people would have
recognized you or something like that
but that's something else
um I'll ask you a question first thing
is do you feel like you have a
purposeful life yes I do alhamdulillah
very good and uh if so what is a purpose
or the purpose of your life
no problem
the creator of the heavens and the Earth
he clear he very clearly stated in the
Quran that he didn't create
Mankind and Jin kind except that they
should worship him so my purpose is to
worship Allah azzawajal the creator of
the heavens and the earth now we're
seeing in Scandinavia more and more
people end their lives now what do you
think the reason for that is it's
obvious
that it's because they don't find the
true purpose of life now if they had
found the true purpose of life if
someone had brought to them the true
purpose of life if someone had actually
given them Dao informed them about the
religion of Islam and that the purpose
of life is to worship Allah I'm
confident that we could save many of
these people's lives and that's exactly
brothers and sisters we're establishing
yes in the whole of Scandinavia and
that's why they're going to click on the
link below because what are you going to
be doing yes we need your support
brothers and sisters to establish this
Masjid that will be doing Outreach that
our work not only in Norway but in the
whole of Scandinavia insha Allah
we're in Sweden we're in Sweden we came
to Sweden to find out what people what
what the purpose of life of the people
are and do they actually have Allah in
their lives or do they don't have we're
collecting data and what have we found
we found that these people they they
lack a deeper purpose of life which
means that it is an obligation Upon Us
Muslims to do something about that we
need to call these people to Islam and
to do that we're establishing the first
of its kind must sit in our Center in
Scandinavia that will be doing Outreach
work inviting people to the way of Allah
and you have the opportunity to be a
part of this work to earn the tremendous
agile of every single person would find
the truth of Islam who would actually
find the purpose of life through this
Dao ascent and these Tower missions that
we do after all of that I can't believe
that they would just sit back and not do
anything else not impossible they're
decent people
they're gonna click the button are they
yeah
come on after all of this not even a
question click the button are you
insulting them no I'm not sure
[Applause]
brother sister just click the button and
make a donation for you
to take part in this area project that
will give you immense rewards not only
throughout your life but all the way up
until the day of judgment
the prophet Muhammad
told us whoever builds a mosque for
Allah Allah will build for him a Sim at
the house in Jannah
and we know the great reward that will
not only be gained but rather will fill
your grave after your death
whenever someone prays there whenever
someone gives shahada in the Masjid
whenever someone learns something in the
Masjid yes that will be something that
you'll have on your scale
foreign